From your secret friend
any of this mean anything to you
you're becoming quite a celebrity
why is he writing to you
Welcome back everyone happy new year you made
it to 2021. this is going to be my new batman
video about the new batman movies there was
a big announcement about all these multiverse
plans that dc has the president of dc films did
a big interview where he explained what their
grand plan is for future batman movies so we'll
break it down because it was a lot of confusion
about who's going to be the new main batman of
dc movies if you're new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos they're still
filming the batman movie with robert pattinson
right now they're going to be filming the flash
movie with ben affleck and michael keaton's batman
really soon too so pretty soon there's going
to be three versions of batman flying around
we'll do a new giveaway for hbo max subscriptions
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and
let me know which new version of batman which new
batman movie you're most hyped up about but if you
have no idea what's going on this last week there
were a bunch of news sites reporting that the
future main batman of the dc eu movies was going
to be michael keaton's batman and he was supposed
to replace ben affleck's batman so naturally a
bunch of ben affleck batman fans were freaking
out like wait a minute they told us they weren't
going to retcon ben affleck's batman out of the
dc eu what's going on there was so much confusion
but a couple days after all the news sites started
reporting this the original person who wrote the
article that everyone had been sourcing as part of
this michael keaton batman claim came out and said
that everybody had gotten it wrong and completely
misinterpreted what he was saying so originally
what happened is the new york times article posted
about the future dc movies in general they did
a big interview with walter hamada who's the
president of dc movies kind of in charge of the dc
cinematic universe of all the movies they're doing
even the movies that aren't connected to the other
dc movies a lot of that article focuses on the way
they're changing their plans about all the dc
movies and the big budget hbo shows that they're
in the middle of making right now like they have
the suicide squad hbo series with john cena they
have the green lantern hbo series all the other
hbo series that they have not announced yet but
that they're working on matt reeves is even making
a batman hbo series that's going to be a spin-off
of his batman movies with robert pattinson so in
the article walter hamada basically says yes they
do have plans going forward to use the concept
of the dc multiverse that they're introducing
in the flash flashpoint movie to explain how
they can have multiple different versions of
batman making new movies at the same time because
previously for the last 40 50 60 years ever since
they've started making batman projects there's
always just been one version of batman on screen
whether it be tvs like adam west's batman or the
movies like michael keaton's batman at any one
time that's why you never saw batman showing up
in the cw shows while they were working on the
dark knight trilogy christopher nolan himself
actually put the band hammer on that he's like
please do not have other versions of batman going
around while i'm working on my dark knight trilogy
if you're a big fan of tom welling superman on
smallville back in the day the whole reason why
they did his show was because originally they had
wanted to do a young batman tv show but because
they were spinning up with the christopher nolan
dark knight trilogy he's like please don't do that
that's why they pivoted to superman but the
whole reason for this big dc multiverse plan
as you probably guessed it is mostly because the
brand new batman robert pattinson's batman movie
is supposed to be set in an alternate universe
matt reeves didn't want to cross over with the
other justice league actors in the other movies
right now but dc wants to continue doing batman
crossovers with other actors because they make
so much more money on those kinds of movies they
want to do more justice league movies and they
can't do that with robert pattinson's batman so
they needed another batman to do that with and
ben affleck had already announced that he was
not going to be batman anymore thus you have them
going back to michael keaton batman to come back
what do we have here but ben affleck is going to
be in the flash movie he's also going to be in the
justice league snyder cut of course we're going to
see that in a couple months the doing a version of
flashpoint batman is very important to the idea
of flashpoint but they're considering matt reeves
batman movies with robert pattinson a completely
separate batman franchise from what's happening
with the regular dceu interconnected movies with
michael keaton now and ben affleck's batman so
because this was also confusing in that original
article in the new york times people were asking
who's the new main batman going to be if you
have all these three different versions of batman
is ben affleck's batman going to be retconned
out is he still going to be the main batman of
the dc eu how are they going to treat michael
keaton's batman when he comes into these movies
his one word answer was just keaton so that's
why you saw all the articles people posting
saying michael keaton was going to be the new main
batman of all the dc movies but a few days after
that the same reporter chimed back in claiming
that everyone could completely misinterpreted the
michael keaton statement he said that he was only
trying to say that michael keaton was going to be
the main batman for the flash movie that they
announced that he was going to be in formally
in that at least right now there's no official
plan that they're ready to announce in place for
him to be the new overall main batman of dc movies
or the interconnected dc movies going forward
normally you would assume though that the main new
batman would be the brand new batman actor that
they cast who is robert pattinson but when matt
reeves signed on to do the batman movie develop
it before he ever cast robert pattinson part of
his deal basically gave him carte blanche to do
whatever he wanted to so he said he wanted to do
a completely self-contained version of batman he
didn't want to deal with all the other movies
all that extra story baggage he just wanted to
do his own little thing his own little bubble of
continuity so because dc wanted a crossover batman
their solution to that was to go back to
michael keaton like what'll get fans really
excited to go see these movies what's a really
cool version of batman that we could go back to
well michael keaton batman was pretty
popular let's go get him to come back
when he was first announced though they also did
say that part of the idea was is they would have
him cross over in other future movies but i think
the part that hasn't been decided yet is exactly
which other movies after the flash movie he would
appear in like everyone would love to see live
action batman beyond and it does sound like they
also want to do that at dc and warner brothers
if things work out but as far as michael keaton
has said he said that they have a lot of cool
things going on behind the scenes we'll see if
it works out as in they're still negotiating over
the timing of everything what he's going to get
paid because if he's going to be doing a bunch of
batman movies in the future a bunch of crossover
movies even if he's not the main character in them
he is still going to get paid bank the funny thing
about matt reeves batman movies though is that
we all saw the set footage of the people in the
halloween costumes for superman and wonder woman
other justice league characters but the version
of the superman costume that was spotted was the
christopher reeve version in that movie is
confirmed to take place relatively close to
present day like iphones were spotted on set in
scenes this lincoln navigator that the riddler
crashes into the old mayor's funeral is also a
late model from relatively recently so clearly
matt reeves isn't afraid of invoking the other
big justice league dc characters i think it's
just the idea that he's not completely ready to do
full-blown crossovers yet so it's probably going
to be a long time before you hear about robert
pattinson's batman crossing over with other movies
if that ever winds up happening but again that's
why they're leaning on the multiverse so hard
so that when they do get to that next justice
league movie if their deal with michael keaton
doesn't work out the way they want it to if he
says no to appearing in those other movies after
the flash movie then they can go back to robert
pattinson and say hey we really want you to do
this we'll give you all this extra money and
they could just have the flash travel to the
other earth and pull batman into their movie then
at the end of that he goes back to his earth for
other matt reeves batman movies there were a lot
of people reporting on social media that robert
pattinson's earth is going to be earth 2 in the
dc multiverse but i don't think that they've given
it an official designation it's just not going to
be the main earth of the dc interconnected movies
the other news that was reported as part of this
big new york times article is that ben affleck's
last movie is supposed to be the flash movie
right now but it didn't say that he would never
come back it's just as right now there's formally
no plans for him to do more batman projects
after the flash movie and zack snyder clarified
what's happening with the justice league snyder
cut in the five potential sequels that he
had planned like he said he had a big five
movie plan so there were other justice league
movies that he originally intended on making
in his own words he says that he has no plans
to continue with the justice league snyder cut 2
with sequels in this storyline universe so the
justice league snyder cut that we see in march
just in a couple months we'll get a new trailer
for that really soon is going to be the last big
justice league story that he intends on telling
at least right now kevin smith was reporting that
it's supposed to end on a really big cliffhanger
type of moment so it could continue in sequels
so i think never say never but at least based
on what zack snyder is saying right now don't
hold your breath on him doing the stories that
he originally intended on doing in his justice
league sequels they will do justice league
sequels but it'll probably be somebody else
to come in and do those and the story will be
different but that doesn't mean that he'll never
do more dc movies or dc projects like other
hbo series he could always come back and do
an hbo series set in the snyder verse it's just
that right now in the near future the next couple
of years there's no current plan for that in place
they will be filming the flash movie with michael
keaton and ben affleck really soon so we'll start
seeing footage of them together hopefully on set
and i'll do videos for whatever winds up happening
zack snyder said that they already have a pretty
clear plan for what their rollout for the justice
league snyder cuts going to be and they're going
to start making more noise about that probably
at the end of this month so there will be a bunch
more big trailers for that dropping really soon
there's a whole bunch of stuff happening this
week so i'll try to get those videos out as fast
as possible make sure you have alerts turned on
for my channel so you don't miss any of that
stuff while you wait for everything click here
for that new deadpool 3 ryan reynolds video that
he just posted and click here for that wonder
woman 1984 post credit scene thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe and happy new year!